I am retired military and I'm drawing
military disability also but I've had to
borrow from some very highin loan places
in order to survive so what is your
military disability income military
retirement I bring home about
1900 a month uh Social Security I bring
home about 2400 disability is 39 are you
married yeah what does she make she does
a Consulting business for a company and
but she doesn't really make anything
everything she makes she puts right back
into it for right now so I think the
challenge is is that the two of you need
to do two things one is you need to sit
down together and get on a detailed
written budget we're going to put you
into Financial pece University and into
every dollar the world's best budgeting
app and I'm going to pay for it as my
gift to you to say thank you for your
service okay